It's my pleasure and honor to welcome professor John O'keeffe today.
Uh,
professor O'keefe is a neuroscientist and professor at the University College
London.
And two years ago,
he won the Nobel prize in medicine for his discovery of place cells in the
brain,
what a scientific American and the Nobel Prize Committee themselves,
uh,
referred to as the positioning system or the gps of the brain works at
University College London and being there for,
for many years.
Uh,
and we're very happy to have him in mountain view today to tell us about the
neural basis of navigation.
[inaudible]
um,
so I,
I guess like most other scientists,
I've always wanted to come to Google,
uh,
and I guess we will have the view is that every scientist should visit Google,
at least once before they die.
So I'm very pleased to be here.
What I've been asked to tell you about,
and,
and of course what I should tell you about is,
is,
is the,
the brain basis of navigation,
how,
how do animals and ourselves,
humans find their way around an environment.
Um,
and what do we know about what mechanisms in the brain or for,
for doing that.
So my title is the hippocampus cognitive map,
neural basis of navigation.
And I'll tell you about how we think humans navigate.
And then I'll tell you about what we know about,
uh,
the areas of the brain,
mostly from work on,
on rodents,
which are involved in,
in this,
in this task.
Well,
let me start with a simple navigation problem.
Um,
it's,
it's based on a,
um,
uh,
properly enough,
a Google map of the,
uh,
of the area around University College London.
And,
um,
one problem one might pose is how does one Gash or,
uh,
what strategies can you use to get from,
um,
the closest,
uh,
underground station,
the closest subway station to university college,
which is here.
Um,
um,
how do you even get from there to,
to university college,
London itself.
And,
um,
in,
in essence what we've been proposing for many,
many years now is that there they're really two general brains strategies for
doing this.
There are actually more,
but there are two general brain surgeries.
One is you come,
you use a route.
Um,
so you have a route strategy,
which is essentially a concatenation of stimulus response,
uh,
strategies,
stimulus response behavior,
um,
where you go from one landmark to the next and each and mark you,
you perform a very specific behavior primarily coded in terms of what we call
egocentric spatial behavior.
How would turn left or right relative to the body axis.
So for example,
if you wanted to get here,
you might,
um,
go out the station,
walk along Euston road,
um,
and then turn right at Gower Street,
and then go about a hundred meters down Gary Street and you'll see the entrance
to UCL and then you enter that.
So that's what we'd call a root strategy.
Um,
and I'm not going to tell you very much more about that.
We think that's a coded in a,
in a very different part of the brain that we in our colleagues have been
studying for many,
many years.
An alternative way of finding your way around,
uh,
the world is to have a kind of a mental representation,
which fulfills all of the properties of having a map,
uh,
in your brain or a gps system.
Um,
and what you would do there is you would have some sort of a grid like
structure,
which would lay out,
uh,
the,
the various geography of,
of the local area.
And you would have,
um,
representations of many of the,
the,
the local landmarks.
First thing you probably would have as the Wellcome trust,
which is one of the major funders,
uh,
of neurobiological research.
You'd have a landmark,
you'd have a representation of the college and to tell other various buildings.
What that would allow you to do is to then not only take essentially the same
route that you,
um,
that you took before you would want to go from this location in your map to this
location.
Um,
and one way to do it will be to follow exactly the same path that you would take
if you were using a root strategy.
But importantly,
it gives you a much greater flexible,
uh,
ability to,
to,
to go from one place to another.
So let's say that normally you would use that mapping structure to move along
Gow Euston road and then take the right down Gary.
But at this point you find that as,
it's not an unusual chemistry has been blocked.
Uh,
they're digging up the,
the,
the pavement,
the digging up the street.
Um,
and what the map will allow you to do,
which the root system won't allow you to do,
is to say,
oh,
I have an alternative strategy I just carry on along Euston square around Euston
Road,
past Easton Square station.
And then I make a right on Gordon Street,
come down and go in through the backdoor.
So it gives you a map,
gives you something that you don't get from a series of roots.
It gives you the ability to go from one place and environment to another
flexibly.
And that's a very,
very powerful,
uh,
ability because it enables you to cope with,
all sorts of alterations in,
in the environment.
So that's what we're going to tell you about.
I'll tell you about how we think we know which parts of the brain,
a human brain and animal brain are involved in representing that structure and
how they,
uh,
that that representation is used to,
to,
to actually,
um,
to navigate.
So let's start then with a question which was actually very,
very difficult one to solve for for many,
many years.
How do you study navigation in reasonably large scale environments?
Um,
in humans and for many years,
uh,
psychologists would routinely studies spatial representations in spatial memory
by having a desktop,
putting a few objects on it,
and ask the subject,
the person to sort of remember where the objects were,
what their relationship was in from our point of view.
That doesn't actually capture the essence of the same system,
which is involved from going from one place in the world to another.
Um,
so in order to do that,
we had to essentially wait for two technical developments.
One was the development of imaging technologies,
first pet and then Fmni,
which enabled us to look at active brain activations,
uh,
under controlled circumstances.
And the other,
since people who are in a brain scanner can't actually move around the world,
uh,
was to have some way in which we could allow them to do that.
And that was the development of virtual reality technologies.
And they first became really available to scientists.
They had been around for a long time,
but you had to be in Hollywood or in a big automotive company to be able to
afford them.
And it was only in the,
in the middle part of the 1990s that all these first person shoot them up games,
uh,
became available and you could buy one for 10,
20 bucks.
So all of a sudden it became available to us impoverished scientists.
Um,
so we realized that if we could use the basic structure of the game,
and this involves getting rid of a lot of aspects of the game.
In this case,
the game game is a Duke Nukem that that would give us a very nice environment,
which will get then use the study,
uh,
to study,
navigation.
And Neil Burgess,
who is at my close colleague for many,
many years,
who has a phd in mathematical physics,
looked at me one day and I looked at him,
he said,
no,
you're not going to ask me to do,
which was to actually essentially take apart the game and get rid of all of the
bits and bobs that we didn't want.
Get rid of the guns,
get rid of all the monsters,
get rid of all the naked women and all those sorts of politically,
uh,
objection of things and leave us with an environment which is actually quite
expensive,
extensive environment.
This is the plan view of the environment.
Um,
and it's about 70 by 70 meters.
People can learn their way around it.
It has all sorts of features.
Um,
and,
and it's actually based on a us,
a rundown suburb of La.
So you get things like general,
like movie theaters.
Um,
and you can see in the distance here,
if you look carefully,
you can see,
uh,
a burning trash can,
um,
as you'd expect.
And there are things like it go inside the cinnamon,
see pictures.
Uh,
this is a blinking eye,
uh,
which is very avant garde motion picture.
I won't tell you what the original picture was.
Um,
and then if you,
if there's,
there are things for,
to see what everybody's tastes,
you can play billiards or pool.
If you're in America,
you can go and get a drink and so on and so forth.
But importantly,
what you have is you have an environment where,
um,
you can move between any two locations by lots of different routes.
So if you want to go from this location and you're told,
showing a picture of the,
uh,
another location,
you can either go directly,
you can go secure this way.
There are lots of independent paths you can take.
So,
um,
with that,
uh,
those two technologies,
Eleanor Maguire at the Ucla,
at Queen Square,
um,
and,
and several of us actually ran the experiment,
which is to see what parts of the brain are activated by this,
this type of navigation using a cognitive representation.
So you let people find their way around,
explore the environment.
An exploration by the way is,
is a,
is,
is a strategy for building our cognitive representation.
You don't explore as far as we can see an environment because you're hungry or
thirsty or anything else.
You don't do it because you're trying to re reduce an immediate biological need.
You do to get a representation and a lot of learning in our view,
it takes that form.
So once they have this map of the,
the environment,
then you can do things like ask them to go from one place to another using that
cognitive representation as opposed to other kinds of representations.
And what we found to our delight,
because as I'll tell you in a minute,
we had always suspected that the human hippocampus as with,
uh,
the animal hippocampus is involved in this kind of of a navigation is that this
area here,
and I'll show you a little bit more of the anatomy of this area,
um,
was one of the two places in the brain that's activated under those
circumstances.
Um,
and this is,
this area here is in effect the hippocampus as I of show you show you.
And the other part of the brain is a part in the parietal cortex up here.
Um,
so as you can see,
this part is right inside the temporal lobes here.
We're inside the temples.
The other part was up here,
which is not shown in this slide.
And those are the two areas now which we think are primarily involved in
navigating in,
in,
uh,
in environments.
Interesting.
Um,
it's not just that that part of the brain is activated,
but the degree of activation,
in this case it was a,
a pet scan.
So it's the amount of blood flow to that part correlates with how good the
navigation is.
So if you have a,
for example,
if you asked the subject to go from ATB,
then of course they can go directly or they can go buy this very long circuitous
route or they can actually get lost.
And if you then take that path and quantify it,
it essentially,
in terms of heading direction,
some Dover over a whole bunch of headings,
directions or do you find is there is a very good correlation between the
activation of this part of the brain,
the hippocampus,
and how good the navigation is.
So it looks as though people who are using their hippocampus and working harder,
uh,
are,
are better at navigating.
Um,
as a follow on from that,
uh,
Eleanor and her,
her,
uh,
student,
you go spears,
um,
started to think about what are their,
any navigators around natural navigators and can we use them for our experiments
and are there any other games?
So they came up with a newly developed game which was developed I think by Sony,
um,
in which they could actually,
you can navigate,
you can drive a taxi cab around,
uh,
around all of London.
So it's a represent very,
very graphic representation of,
of most of the streets of,
at least in a London.
And here are a couple of screenshots from that.
And you can see that if you ask somebody to navigate,
I start from this part of London and go to the tense on a certain part of the
Thames,
you get a path that looks something like this.
Interestingly enough,
um,
what you can ask then the,
the,
the subject,
in this case,
the taxicab driver,
um,
is to actually,
uh,
w you can ask which parts of the brain are,
have become active at certain parts of that navigation.
Um,
and you can effectively read their mind or flying.
So what you do is you re you record the,
the,
the behavior that they're driving from one place to another.
And then,
um,
after that and you look at the,
the brain activations and after that you replay the video of their,
of their,
um,
of their route and you say,
okay,
what were you thinking at the time in which you are dislocation?
And very interesting,
Lee,
it turns out that having a spatial framework,
uh,
on which to lay down memories makes it very easy,
at least in the short term,
to recall those memories.
So the cab driver would say,
boom,
I was thinking about where am I going to go?
So I was planning my route at the bit and then he's driving.
He said,
well,
I'm driving along one of the main routes so I don't need to think too hard about
that.
Uh,
and I'll look,
this guys is coming out of the side corner here.
I Better Watch out.
Oh,
I didn't expect to see that.
So there's a whole narrative that goes with it and they can remember that
narrative with extreme detail.
And then so you can then use that to map onto the activation.
Not only that,
it became this part of the whole brain and see which parts of the brain are,
are actually activate.
And to make a long story short,
what you see is that they have a campus,
at least in these circumstances,
is actually activated maximumly when the Cabbie is actually planning the road.
So when you get into the cab and say,
I want to go here,
he plans the roof and then he doesn't need to work the hippocampus so hard.
And as I say,
you can look at all sorts of other things,
which part of the brain is activated when you're actually seeing somebody coming
out or something unexpected.
Anyway,
that of course leads onto one of Eleanor Maguire is most famous studies was
realizing that you got expert navigators in the form of London.
Taxi cab drivers means that you could do things like say,
well,
is there any part of their brain which is actually particularly involved in this
expertise?
And it is an expertise.
Uh,
uh,
the Google is putting,
its changing as it's doing this.
Lots of things.
It's changing landscape.
But until recently to become a London taxi cab driver,
you had to actually learn all about 25,000 streets in London and how you went
from one street to another.
Um,
which is quite a formidable,
um,
uh,
mental representation.
It takes about three years on average to acquire what's called the knowledge.
And these people really can do that and they cannot only do that,
but they can actually modify their route on the basis of a daily information,
uh,
traffic,
information and things like that.
Um,
I don't want to say anything about my original hometown,
but I was a cab driver in New York and I can assure you I didn't have anything
like that,
uh,
knowledge of,
of,
of New York at the time.
And when you do that,
what you find interestingly enough is that if you look at this part of the
brain,
the hippocampus,
it's larger in taxicabs,
particularly the posterior part,
the part towards the back,
which is the part where we think is very,
very,
uh,
importantly engage in,
in navigation is larger in,
in,
in cab drivers than it is in,
uh,
average people,
in the,
uh,
in the population.
And SPUs interestingly enough,
both larger than you,
like you find in,
in,
in bus drivers,
um,
who of course go around city streets but don't have to exercise this,
this complex cognitive ability.
Um,
and interesting that the longer someone has been a cab driver,
the larger the part of the brain becomes.
So it's not as though you're born,
um,
with a large hippocampus and then you become a cab driver.
It actually is that you're using it in some aspect of this.
We're not sure exactly what aspect of the hippocampus represented in these,
in these,
uh,
anatomical studies.
And when people stop being cab drivers,
then it relaxes back to through the average average size.
Uh,
and that that's shown here.
Time is cab driver in months and,
and,
and the the size here.
Okay.
So,
um,
we're pretty sure this part of the brain in humans is essential for the kind of
cognitive navigation that were interested in.
It looks as though it's doing other things as well.
And I'll come back to that if,
if,
if we want to discuss that at the end.
Eh,
it looks as though it's more generally involved in what we call episodic memory,
the ability you have for remembering what you do in a particular location at a
particular time,
uh,
in,
in the past and,
and so you can see what we're,
what the relationship is.
If you had a spatial memory system and then you add it in,
say time and a few other things,
that would be the way in which you would build up a more general memory system.
Okay.
So let me tell you a little bit about anatomy.
This is the hippocampus,
the,
uh,
the old anatomists in the 16th centuries.
What this looked like a sea horse,
and that's why they call it the hippocampus.
Uh,
some of them thought it looked like a worm on its back.
it's,
uh,
as you know,
most anatomical structures were named,
uh,
with the Latin or Greek,
um,
uh,
name for the,
what the structure looked like in gross anatomy.
Um,
this is the hippocampus in humans.
This is the hippocampus in,
in animals.
Um,
and interestingly enough,
if you look at the,
the,
uh,
the structure of the self cellular structure of Sido architect tonic structure
of the,
uh,
the,
this area in lots of different animals,
it looks more or less the same.
We are sure that it does.
There are additional things that it does,
but at least on the first pass,
it looks like it has the same structure.
So you can look at it in a,
in a,
in a rodent or in a,
in a primate or,
or in human beings.
And it has the same structure.
And we know quite a bit,
uh,
about the detailed structure of it.
I won't go into any detail.
We know about the cells that make up the,
the,
the cell layers.
Um,
and,
uh,
we know about the interconnections with the,
between those cells and also between those cells and other areas in the brain,
which are afferent to the,
um,
to the hippocampus.
And specifically,
if we look at this area here,
this color coded map,
uh,
this is the,
the hippocampus.
And interestingly enough,
there are a whole bunch of structures around the hippocampus.
Um,
the antiviral Cortex,
the speculum Prisa Bacon,
which primarily in send information into the hippocampus and they'll be relevant
in a second.
As I tell you what the cells in these different parts of the brain,
um,
do.
So how do we go about finding out what sells in a part of the brain?
Uh,
do,
um,
in rodents,
well,
um,
for many years now we in many,
many others have been using the following techniques.
Um,
what we do is we place electrodes into a part of the structure under deep
anesthesia and then allow the animal to recover from the anesthetic.
And the electrodes are such that we can place them,
we can move them into areas of the cell cell structure of the neuro structure so
that we can record the activity of single cells,
um,
as the animal is engaging in lots of different behaviors.
Um,
and what we find,
this is a typical exam experiment,
um,
and the animals running around in a very simple box.
In this case a square box.
It could be a circle of acts.
Uh,
we were watching where the animal is with an overhead camera so that we can
locate its position,
say 10 times per second.
And we can also say where the animal is when the cell becomes active.
And what we find is that it sells in various parts of the hippocampus,
but particularly in this what's called the ca one subfield,
um,
become active when the animal goes to a specific location.
And that really interested in why the animal goes there so much or even what it
does there,
they're interested in where he does this thing.
So if you record in Sean Black here,
all of the,
so if you record in a situation like this where the animal is foraging around
looking for bits of food thrown into the environment,
uh,
randomly,
what you get behaviorally is a coverage of the entire environment.
So as shown in the black years,
and we're talking about 10 minutes worth of recording,
and what you find is that these cells are of silent most of the time,
but that when the animal goes to a particular part of the box,
the cell becomes active,
it wakes up and it shows this standard activation patterns.
And you can use a heat map that represent that activation where the,
the,
the horror colors represent the higher levels of activation.
So this,
for example,
is a cell which fires doesn't become active in most of the box but then becomes
active when the animal goes here and particularly when it goes to this location
here.
So when you see that immediately strikes you that this is a cell which is
telling the rest of the nervous system where the animal is.
Interestingly enough,
um,
it was very obvious right from the beginning,
even in the 1970s that,
uh,
the cells had very interesting properties.
So for example,
if you take a cell here,
recording this cylinder and you record it and you see where the cell fires,
if the fire's here virtually in the center of the cylinder,
if you then break apart that Dataset so that it,
uh,
you represent what the cell does when the animal is heading north or South or
east or west through that particular area,
then you get these pictures here.
In other words,
it cell is quite happy to fire if the animal is running north or south or east
or west.
From a,
in an environment like this,
it varies a bit with the environment in an environment like this.
It looks as though the sales representing the location and not,
uh,
something about,
some particular stimulus in the external world.
Um,
equally importantly,
if you record from that one,
but lots of these cells,
in this case,
32 of them at the same time and ask how did they differ from each other?
What you find is that each one has one or sometimes two preferred locations,
but they're all different.
So if you just look at the activity of 32 cells and then we're talking about a
small subsection of,
uh,
hundreds of thousands of cells in this part of the brain
and you line up the fields,
they're not lined up in the brain,
but if you wind them up,
uh,
in,
in the representation,
would you see,
is that wherever the animal is,
if it's,
for example,
in the northwest corner on the northeast corner or running between the two
areas,
there is a cell which represent that location.
And similarly coming down the,
the west side or the east side or their wrongs and even in the center.
So very quickly you get the impression that the ensemble of cell activity is
actually representing the whole of an environment.
And that's duplicated over and over again across many,
many cells in the hippocampus.
Well,
if you see that it's,
I guess in retrospect,
it doesn't take a lot of imagination to say,
well,
maybe this is the part of the brain which forms a map like representation of the
salt that I told you about right at right at the beginning.
Um,
and so,
um,
uh,
looking at lots of the early literature on the effects of damage in the
hippocampus and,
and other,
uh,
things that we knew back in the 1970s,
um,
a chap called Lynch,
a Dell who is now in Arizona and myself suggested just that at this part of the
brain is in some sense a cognitive map.
Um,
now it turns out if you think about it having a bunch of place representation's
having a bunch of representations of the sort,
I just showed you where the,
the,
the brain is sorta signaling where the animal is,
isn't enough to produce a map.
A map requires something more.
Uh,
and specifically the map requires not only information about places but also the
distances and directions.
It needs to have in one representation a set of vectors which actually called
not for just the location of the animal is currently,
uh,
occupying.
But what,
how that location is related to other locations in the environment.
You need to know the distance and direction between different places to have a
map.
And it's that it's second type of representation,
which is what gives the system the power,
which enables you to move from one place to another.
So for example,
um,
if you had a representation of,
of a place a and you knew that you wanted to go to place B,
perhaps you have stored memory that there was food there,
then the system should be able to generate this,
this factory and that,
send that to the motor system and drive the system,
uh,
in the,
in the right direction.
However,
if this path is blocked,
then the system should equally well be able to generate any set of vectors which
would get you to the right plate.
So you will be able to do simple vector Algebra and know that Ac plus CB catch
you back to the same place.
So that was the idea and that's the idea that we and many others have been
pursuing for a long time now.
And I'll show you the evidence from at least behavioral studies,
which suggests that that might be the right thing.
Okay,
well if you make a specific prediction about uh,
the fact that an area has these kinds of properties and the first thing you do
is you go looking for the other kinds of cells.
So if you think that the,
in addition to places,
there should be representations of distances and directions,
then you should go look for them.
And I spent a lot of time looking for these other cells in the hippocampus,
the place that I've just in hippocampus proper and didn't find them or at least
only found little slight hints of it.
Some other people in particularly a man called Jim Rohn in,
in,
in New York went looking in those other areas,
those areas that are associated with the hippocampus and are very tightly
connected.
And found both,
uh,
he found the first kind of representation,
which is a direction representation of directions.
And now recently the Moses have found representations of what we originally
thought was distance.
So I'll tell you a little bit about those and then I'll tell you a little bit
about how we use behavioral studies to try to understand how the system works.
So I've shown you this map already and what we now know on the basis of some of
our work but mostly work in other laboratories is that these place cells that
coming up,
um,
which are found mostly in the hippocampus here,
uh,
and which are representing the animals location or showing the heat map and
don't care as shown in this polar plot,
which represents how the cell responds to heading direction.
Um,
they're found mostly in,
in,
in the hippocampus proper.
But if you want these other cells and you have to look at outside the
hippocampus proper and these associated areas here,
um,
and when you do that,
if you look for example in this area here,
the pre speculum,
then you find these head direction cells.
You find cells here,
which don't particularly care as shown in heat map where the animal is,
but care very,
very,
uh,
very much about the,
the,
the heading direction.
So that is a cells which fire whenever the animal is looking in a particular
direction,
regardless of where it is an environment.
And uh,
and another kind of cell that was discovered by the Moses and Moses lab,
uh,
are these grid cells which have not just a single location where the cell fires
but are a multiple set of locations.
And interestingly,
those,
the peaks of those firing pattern are located in what looks like,
um,
either depending on your,
your,
uh,
predilection,
either a hexagonal structure or a,
an equal lateral triangular structure.
So if you look at it as structure of firing like that,
whereas the animal goes around the environment,
the cell goes Burp,
burp at equally spaced locations.
Then your first,
and I have to say,
our first assumption was that this is something telling the brain and the animal
about the actual distances.
It's going in a particular direction.
I,
it's a,
it's a metric system for cognitive map.
We think that recent work in our own lab and other labs are probably going to
modify that overall impression of bitch because we see we can distort this,
this grid structure,
um,
in,
in ways that won't have time to tell you.
Um,
but you will,
that means in their other selves,
I won't go into the boundary cells,
which more or less signal lead the distance,
the distance from walls of the environment.
But we think now that we have all of the types of representations that we need
to create a cognitive mapping structure.
Okay.
And I just want to now spend the next five minutes or so telling you about just
how we go about addressing some of the other questions about,
about these cells.
So for example,
um,
as frank said,
I spent,
uh,
quite a bit of time at Grumman aircraft making,
making airplanes.
Really,
I wouldn't make too much,
but I was kind of a junior engineer at the time.
It was early in my career.
I was studying engineering at Nyu.
Um,
but even then we knew that for example,
um,
in addition to using the,
the,
the environmental cues that you can see from a low flying airplanes you can use,
you can use inertial navigation systems to calculate how far in a particular
direction that the plane has gone.
And uh,
and there are all kinds of sensors on the plane.
Uh,
so for example,
their thing of tubes and things like that,
which will it actually monitor that,
that uh,
those in as it were self generated movement signals.
So when we got to the point of studying this cognitive navigation system,
it was pretty natural for us to start thinking,
well,
maybe there are two systems in the brain but doing that.
So the idea is that each one of these place cells has two ways of knowing where
the animal is.
The one is look around,
see the cues and calculate on the basis of triangulation of queues,
where,
where the animal is.
But the other is once the animal knows it's in a particular location and it has
a representation of that environment,
it can then use these internally generated internal inertial navigation signals.
How far the animal has gone in a particular direction to calculate an update the
map.
So I can say,
okay,
I know where I am,
I turn around and walk in a certain direction that should activate.
So the internals system,
the internal,
what we call the path integration system,
should also be capable of activating the system.
So how do you study those two inputs into,
into this,
these cells?
Well,
you can try lots of things like putting the armor on treadmills and things like
that and it's really quite hard to pull apart the,
those two sources of information,
particularly because one of them,
the,
the system which uses as it were,
self generated motion signals involves things like uptick flow.
And so you,
you,
you're,
you're getting signals opticals visual signals or contributed to about six.
So this is a famous painting.
Um,
uh,
I think it's 15th century by period.
Della Francesca and uh,
it's about the creation of price.
Who's is back here,
um,
being a flagellated in,
in the,
um,
in the presence of,
of,
of punches pilot.
And there are three Tuscan noblemen who are completely ignoring this scene,
standing here,
probably talking about the price of,
of wishing or wine more likely,
uh,
in the local markets.
Then what I use it to show is,
is how,
um,
they can represent their location in this environment using these two,
two different strategies.
So for example,
this chap can say,
well,
I know where I am here.
Um,
because I can look at all these different objects and I can see where I am
relative to those,
to those objects.
And we're pretty sure that's one of the ways in which humans and animals,
uh,
make it.
But in addition to that,
once he knows where he is and say he wants to go over to a another place,
he wants to get closer to the scene and actually see,
uh,
what,
what is going on.
A while he could just move until he gets,
uh,
the same signals from the same landmarks,
which represent that location.
But you could also use this path integration system.
He could turn around 180 degrees.
Then Piro is made a little easier for them by laying a tile and grid structure
on the,
on the floor so that he could follow that and turn it around 180 degrees,
walk a certain distance,
turn right and go to the,
so you'd use this internal signals to update his location.
And,
and,
and I'll show you right now that we think that that's what,
what animals are doing as well.
So over the years,
Neil Burgess and other people who were working with me using virtual reality
test the system in humans,
I said,
why can't we just do this with rats?
I mean,
we've been running around all environments and everything.
Why do we have to do all last fall out?
Why can't we just use virtual reality to sort of present the world to them?
Uh,
and uh,
and then study the system.
And I have to say,
I was a naysayer,
I said for many,
many years,
it's not gonna work.
They are like the having a heads fix they don't like.
And it certainly is true that rats don't,
but it turns out the mice too.
They don't mind having a heads fact as long as they have something to run on.
So if you put a my view looking at it and have a pet mouse,
what the mouse does is he spends all his time running on,
on running wheels important and you need to give them that in order to keep them
happy when you got them.
Um,
and so a chap called David tank who was originally at bell labs but it's now
been at Princeton for some time.
Uh,
and his students device a rash or mouse version is really,
really for mice.
I have to be careful here because that's really,
nobody's done it properly for rats yet a mouse virtual reality environment where
the animals had is fixed.
It runs on a styrofoam ball,
which is floating on a cushion of air so that the ball turns almost
frictionlessly.
Um,
and the world is presented to the animal,
um,
on this,
on these two video screens.
And this is a screenshot of what it looks like and I'll show you as you run into
it.
Essentially what we're looking at is a one dimensional environment.
In this situation we haven't really been able to get the animal to navigate in
two dimensions very well.
Um,
and we know where he's going because there's a simple computer mouse which
distracts the movement of the ball.
So here is the animal is placed down.
Yeah.
Uh,
and,
and this is work done by Griffin Chen and John King.
He's placed at the start of this,
this track here and their cues on the side and the accused at the end.
And his job is just to run to the end and get food and then he's teleported back
to the start again and runs again and back to the start again.
So in from,
from point of view of collecting a lot of data,
it's very nice.
And also he tells us where it is.
We can do things like not only have food at the end where we get halfway down
and show that he knows where the location of the food is.
And this is what the representation,
easy way of representing this whole environment is.
You have a yellow track here and then they're accused dotted around the crap
track.
So this is what it looks like,
uh,
on a,
this is a screenshot at the start and here's what it looks like as he runs down
from the animal's point of view.
So he stands there and now he starts to run and you'll hear one of these place
cells fire as it gets to about halfway down.
Okay?
So that's a,
a bunch of clicks which are standing in for the firing it.
He's then teleport back to the beginning of the Po,
the amaze again,
and he runs again.
And the sellers,
you'll see fires in the same place.
Okay?
Okay.
So we can get,
we can essentially show that these cells treat this artificial virtual world as
the adult were real world.
And we can do a lot of experiments.
Let me tell you a few on this.
We can find cells that fire,
uh,
some way down the track in this case at the beginning in this case,
um,
uh,
in the middle.
And we can record from new for several days under the best circumstances.
And we get ask things like,
well,
which Kuser the,
the,
uh,
the cells using.
Um,
so we can show that a cell which fires in the middle if you take those visual
cues away.
And of course we've created this world.
It's an artificial world that's only has,
so we'd be a bit surprised that he's still new and a bit unhappy if he still
knew where the NSL knew where to fire,
but they don't.
And it turns out it's of cues on the side and not the cute that is approaching
her or,
or leaving,
which are the important cues.
Um,
and interesting enough on a,
for some of the cells,
about a quarter of them,
we can pass a renewed the animal down the environment and the sales so far.
So he doesn't act that we have to,
uh,
write down three quarters them.
He has to actively run down.
But for some of them it's just passive movement.
Now the ones that are actively very actively runs down are interesting because
what we'd like to study is how these two sources of information,
information given by the visual world and the given by his own path and his own,
uh,
movements,
which essentially you're telling him how,
when to expect the cues,
how they integrate,
integrate with each other.
And one way is,
is shown on this slide.
If he knows where he is,
you show them the cues.
Then Ken,
this is internal movement system,
update the representation after the case had been removed.
So we show them the cues and then the minute he starts to move,
we take the keys away and see what the cell does.
And for about half of the cells they show this kind of behavior.
We put them down on the stock and he runs down in the cell fires again in the
middle if we take the cubes away.
So he has no clue as to where he is even at the start and the cells don't fire.
But if we put him down at the beginning of the,
the track and then as he starts to move,
we turned the lights off,
then the cells still fires in a bike place showing that these two sources of
information are actually integrating.
We have a sensory signal.
The visual cues is being integrated with information coming from the vestibular
system and the proprioceptive system in the motor system.
Okay.
So,
um,
that's the end of my story.
Um,
we think there's a very strong information in this story has been going for
about 40 years now.
Uh,
that the part of the brain called the hippocampus or the hippocampal formation.
You provide something like a cognitive map in,
in animals and it can be used to identify their location and to navigate.
And we think there,
the system does the same thing in humans.
Uh,
it's used,
uh,
actually,
as a basis for a broader memory system.
Uh,
an episodic memory system.
Um,
and there are two strategies for locating places.
One is to use the cues.
It's not just visual.
We tend to use visual envision tends to be the strongest.
Q,
a,
if you pick different modalities against each other,
the animal,
even though it's visual system is,
is,
is much,
uh,
less,
he has a much less accuracy than a,
an acuity then then you would get in primates,
they still use that.
So a bad visual system if you're trying to navigate is better than a good
auditory system I guess.
Um,
uh,
and then,
the other system is this path integration system,
which is,
um,
which is uh,
using information about movements,
primarily vestibular and probably we think,
uh,
information from the motor system of predicting what the actual movements are
going to be.
And these are the people who have funded us.
The,
uh,
I met Ucl Gatsby foundation and the Wellcome trust has been funding is for many
years and together they've gotten together in Builtin a new center for the study
of,
of systems neuroscience for the study of how cells integrate.
Yeah.
Selten,
not only the hippocampus but other parts of brain,
how they integrate and talk to each other to form these,
these representations.
So thank you for your attention.
Thank you for your,
I was interested in the density of spacial memory.
So given the size of the cells and the size of hippocratic campus,
can you predict how many places we can remember or recognize?
And I guess with the taxi driver growing the hippocampus,
you know,
is,
is that an indication as well?
So I think that
problem is we don't really know how many cells you need to represent any,
any,
anything.
Uh,
cognitively.
Um,
the other problem which I,
I kind of didn't go into is that both in the hippocampus and the place cells in
the hippocampus and also the grid cells in the [inaudible] Cortex,
um,
they're not all representing things at the same scale.
And in fact it's,
there's a systematic change in scale as you go from one end of the hippocampus
and [inaudible] Cortex to deal.
And it looks like there were four or five levels of,
of,
of uh,
scale.
So it's a quantum jump in scale.
Uh,
and there are five of those as you go from one entity,
the next,
particularly in the grid cells where we know more about it.
So,
and,
and the scale actually gets fairly large.
So that,
for example,
we usually use boxes of a couple of meters by a couple of minutes,
but some of the cells in the,
in the,
um,
uh,
far down in the,
in this,
in this level where the scales are quite big,
might represent an entire room.
So this,
so in terms of,
we would have to think about it in terms of each of these different mapping
systems to get that answer.
But it looks as though the,
the representations are actually quite local and small in one end.
And then they get quite large and global and the other end.
And presumably these parts of the brain are talking to each other.
So the computation is,
is a little more difficult than just asking how many,
uh,
environment or,
or what's a dent.
The acuity.
The other thing is we don't have any good right now.
Any good methodology for assessing acuity,
special acuity.
We don't know how good an animal can tell behaviorally,
uh,
tell us how,
how,
how well you can identify this location as opposed to the neighboring location.
So until we have that information,
it's going to be difficult to do that calculation.
You,
you showed a picture of the hippocampus,
kind of a structurally,
can you say anything about how the structure of the hippocampus in the brain
differs from maybe other parts of the brain and any ideas on why that might mean
that's where place cells occur?
Yeah,
that's a very good question.
Um,
so many people have tried to do a function structure relationships for,
uh,
for many years.
The hippocampus is a form of cortex.
It's a form of primitive cortex.
It doesn't have all the layers.
And the intermodal cortex doesn't have all of the layers with cells in it that
you would get in the neocortex.
Um,
what's nice about it is the unanimous had been studying it for many as have the
physiologists been studying it for many,
many years because it's such a beautifully simple structure.
So the cells that we record from,
uh,
the,
the place cells are almost definitely pyramidal cells in the hippocampus.
And that's probably the most studied a brain cell.
And it's the most studied cell in the brain and others.
And if so,
if you're a physiologist and you want to look at a membrane potentials are you
want this look at transmitters you quite often we'll go to the hippocampus cause
it's got a very nice simple structure.
Um,
one of the things in terms of the question you ask is,
um,
is there anything about it that would give us some clues?
And it,
if you were a computational neuroscientists and you looked at the structure as
somebody like David Moore did in the 19th sentence,
you will almost automatically say,
look,
this looks like some sort of a continuous attractor network because of what you
get is a huge density of,
of interconnections between the principal cell types.
So not only do they have inputs coming in from the outside,
but they actually talk to each other and,
and they,
they,
the structure is such as it looks as though each cell talks to lots.
And lots of other cells.
So it looks as though there is a lot of communication within the structure and
the other kind of structural feature,
which seems to implicate,
uh,
something like a,
an associate network is that each fiber as it comes in runs along lots and lots
of cells.
So it provides information for,
for many,
many of the cells,
uh,
at the same time.
And in some way the cells sought out the fact that they have many,
many inputs in common by using an inhibitory network and his like a first past
the post inhibitory network where the,
whoever gets the fire first uses the local inhibitory inhibitory network tech
suppress the activity of all the,
all the neighbors.
So it's only the cells who are,
uh,
as it were at a certain distance,
which can also fire in the same place because the local,
and that's some extent,
we explains that map that I showed you where all the cells of which are in a
local environment seem to have sort of space themselves out optimally to,
to,
to get the,
the right.
Uh,
it's a fire across the whole environment.
So there are lots of hints,
uh,
if you just came from the other direction in the anatomical direction,
and I don't think you would necessarily think that there,
that would lead you to think they were a spatial system.
You can only do that on the basis of the physiology.
Right.
I wonder if you've looked at the correlation between,
um,
direction of gravity versus the resolution of locationing,
uh,
like for example,
doing the same experiment with tilted platform,
different angles.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a good question too.
So,
um,
it,
it's clear that gravity is,
is,
is operating here and mostly on the cells which are involved in a setting up the
head direction,
a signal,
and we know a bit about that.
And,
and,
um,
it,
uh,
if you turn the animal side down in the signal is lost.
So there has to be something which,
which tells says the direction of gravity.
Um,
other than that,
I'm not so sure that we know much more about that.
We,
um,
we know that most of our work is in two dimensions.
Uh,
so we don't explore that very much.
Kate,
Jeffrey,
one of my colleagues at Ucl has tried to look at the third dimension by having
animals,
climbing towers and things like that.
The best way to do it is to have an animal that actually naturally,
uh,
behaves in a three dimensional environment.
And the best example of that is working in Israel,
um,
where they,
uh,
by a chap called and ask and his colleagues where they have that's flying around
in three dimensional environments.
And so there we see the same,
more or less the same thing except you get a three dimensional thing.
So in addition to,
um,
the,
uh,
say one of these head direction cells,
pointing towards the Asmis and sort of giving you the,
the,
that uh,
um,
that,
that single,
they also show pitch.
They don't seem to care too much about your and things like that.
So there is a gravity signal,
but it hasn't been studied very much.
We're involved in doing machine navigation and locations.
Do you think there's anything that we can learn from like how the brain does it
as how we should approach it or should we maybe rely on on intelligent design
analytically instead of organically?
I guess that's it.
A more general question then the relationship between brains and how brains do
it in artificial intelligence.
And there are a lot of similar questions.
Invasion for example.
And um,
I remember once when the,
in the,
in the early days I'm talking to one of the pioneers of artificial intelligence
and,
and he said,
well,
we're going to come up with a way of solving this problem,
uh,
algorithmically.
And I said,
well,
I don't really care about that.
I want to know how the brain does it.
He said,
well,
actually made,
they may not be a lot of ways of doing this.
So if you had one way of doing it,
that would give you a lot of hints about how to do it.
So I guess that if you accept what I've been telling you that I'm having sort of
one good example of how you can do it.
There probably are other ways of doing it,
but,
uh,
and they probably probably a ways which are very different,
but having one good way,
uh,
and especially in terms of the flexibility of the,
of the,
of the structure might,
might,
uh,
might actually give you clues as to how to do it yet.
So thanks very much.
So.
[inaudible].